the year was 1996. it was a different
era before memes before viral videos
before anybody argued over whether it's
a gift for a jiff it's gift jiffy's
peanut butter there was the dancing baby
[Music]
what is the dancing baby who better to
ask than its father michael gerard what
are you doing here
the dancing baby remember the dancing
baby uh well robert lurier and i worked
together to design the animation the
idea was to show
that movement could be programmed and
projected onto different characters so
autodesk the company that michael worked
for started sending around the software
to other developers and animators
it was just another demo film until it
landed on the lucasarts server it was
there that ron lucia tweaked the
original file converted it into a gif
and sent an email that would change his
life forever so we thought we should ask
ron about his experience but
[Music]
every time that you've got male voice
ranked welcome
you've got mail
files done
goodbye
it was another goddamn dancing baby even
i got an email of the goddamn dancing
baby from that point on it was
unstoppable everywhere you looked there
was a dancing baby on television on
t-shirts on ties and commercials
even boxers
boxers
yes michael boxers
this all begs the question what is it
about the dancing baby that makes it so
irresistible and what does it say about
us
have you heard of the uncanny valley
it's a paradox where the more a
computer-generated figure resembles a
human the more we become revolted by it
the dancing baby is the uncanny valley
the dancing baby is the uncanny valley
it's been over two decades since gerard
and his team unleashed their monstrosity
on the world does he regret it
yes
100 percent
[Music]
you